The Legend of Zelda is quite possibly  the most anticipated Wii U game ever and  producer I egl Numa has implied that  development may finally be coming to a  close he also said it could have the  same impact as ocarina of time on the  Nintendo 64 I'm Tony and this is your  hyrulean gamespot news updates speaking  to feminine I'll Numa said he wants  Zelda Wii U to be somethin as new and  surprising as Zelda on the n64 in fact  ocarina of time is the basis for the new  game he said quote this time the change  in flavor will be like going from  Japanese food to western style food  perhaps players will be surprised that's  certainly an interesting way to pitch  the game Zelda for Wii U has no official  release date but it is heavily rumored  to be releasing this holiday we'll  probably have to wait until e3 before we  hear more in the meantime you can keep  an eye on gamespot for any new  developments and for all the Zelda news  you need you're already in the right  place  you